eighteen-month-old Parma ham imported
hams and cheeses from Italy have been
increasing in popularity in Germany for
decades the German palate has reoriented
towards the south that has helped the
business of Virgilio Tyrone these
doodles are from Campania Solano right
where I came from I left there in 1964
he has about 5000 Italian products on
offer for German customers his wholesale
business now Frankfurt has a turnover of
seven million euros a year the economic
crisis in Italy has led to higher prices
many of his Italian suppliers are
struggling to survive not all of them
unlikely to make it just this week I got
a call from one he said with Giulio I
have a lot of problems in Italy I can't
keep up with my bills I built it all
myself and now probably I'll lose
everything
buried under debt relief eel for them I
know them personally me Alicia like oh I
wish Kendall from director on the crisis
of Italy is apparent here as well at a
marketing exposition and mannheim
Italian firms are looking for sales reps
in Germany the Italian Chamber of
Commerce and southern Germany says twice
as many Italian companies are now
seeking their assistance there are many
companies with wonderful products which
in the past may not have spent that much
time in terms of marketing their image
abroad as mom's now they are because of
the economic situation they have good
products they just need to sell them but
that includes products such as window
insulation as well as tools and
machinery for the construction and
automobile making industries but
challenges do remain even for those
companies taking the effort to market
themselves in Germany
the Italians have been very slow to
incorporate new developments they're not
as flexible as in the past it seems to
me there is less flexibility this year
everyone is being very very cautious the
companies know that they are having
trouble getting credit to develop new
products and conduct research there is a
lot of stagnation in this area in
December 8th nevertheless traffic from
Italy to Germany is increasing this
German transportation firm does two
thirds of its business with Italy many
of its trucks now return to Italy empty
the downturn there means German sales to
Italy have slumped because of corn
laughs ha the total volume to Italy is
definitely down and it's definitely
continuing to sink how much do you think
I'd say about 20% really go the economic
crisis in southern Europe is hitting
German firms right now many are hoping
for a stable government in Italy
so this is the RV Schuyler I don't have
any more investments planned for this
year it's all on hold right now that's
just the way it is the fate of this
small firm may ultimately depend on the
question many are asking in Europe
whereas Italy's economy headed